okay i guess we're live
uh the 90 day challenge is over
uh that doesn't doesn't mean that we
stop uh studying language by the way i'm
going to try to get my
screen up because i'm going to share
some things with you here just hold on a
sec
and um
yeah okay so you know 90 days i studied
harder in these 90 days than i normally
would i
assigned myself the task of working on
two languages i'm not sure i would do
that again but you never know
one thing about these 90-day challenges
we learn about a language we learn more
about a language really get our noses
into the language
uh we also learn about ourselves we
learn about what we like to do
we learn
new approaches to language learning we
maybe get some different perspectives on
language learning and some of those
things i'm going to share with you
uh today so uh i did my
call it exit interview in arabic
uh last time and i have a uh
session with my uh one of my farsi or
persian tutors at 11 and i'm going to
record myself oh i forgot to bring my
phone up here uh talking to her so that
you can get a sense of what i achieve
have achieved in persian
so what did we learn or what did i learn
and what am i going to take from that
going forward
so one of the things that happened with
my both my arabic and persian
uh first of all let's let's take one
thing right away and dismiss it and
that's the thought somehow when we are
older
uh we can't learn languages
i have said this many times i'm a better
language or learner now at the age of 73
than i was at the age of 20. i am
learning languages faster
for two reasons one because i'm more
confident that i can do it i have a
better sense of how to go about doing it
and b
the
uh technology
uh the availability of content
uh it's just so much better now
and in particular i have found that in
my last three or four languages
that as i've said again i've said before
i find the many stories a very powerful
way
uh to get where you can actually start
saying something in a language now
this brings me to one of my observations
in arabic and persian
i have been much more sort of
let's say reluctant or i have found it
more difficult to move out of
the sort of beginner environment or
beginner to early intermediate material
into more demanding material so when i
was learning
even romanian but certainly um czech or
polish
i was able to get into
uh you know the wonderful
tolkie cesco minelos di which is this
czech series on czech radio about czech
history
uh
and with russian i was into russian
audiobooks very early and and durgeniev
and tolstoy and stuff so i was moving
into meaty things earlier i was even
listening to
romanian podcast on romanian history and
able to get you know a fair amount of it
after a couple of months
none of this has been true with arabic
and persian
and i think there are a number of
reasons for that and i'm going to show
you you know my
progression in different languages and
you can compare that to your own
experience
the arabic script is difficult because
it's not
one-to-one like spanish
or even hangul in korean where once you
know the writing system if you see the
word you can read it you can pronounce
it
it's not so easy so it's taking me a
long time to get used to
reading in those languages i continue to
struggle i continue to make mistakes i
continue to pronounce them wrong with
arabic i have the advantage that we have
text to speech however inaccurate the
text to speech is it gives me a sense of
how to pronounce the word i can then
confirm the pronunciation
when i listen to the
natural voice but in persian we don't
have that
so harder to read
also in any european language there are
so many freebie words
now that was less the case when i
did my first slavic language russian
although even in russian there are a lot
of words that are
from other european languages whether
latin or greek or french or german so
there are words there that help you
uh
persian the only advantage in persian is
that there are a lot of words from
arabic so that helps
so it's more difficult to move into more
challenging material
um
and
so i i felt i wanted to kind of
improve
my basic level more i wanted to read
more i wanted to get better at reading
all of this so that spending i was
spending more time in warming up
for
eventually attacking more difficult
material and also
i wanted to be able to speak better this
is never something that's
been a preoccupation before
because in these other languages
i'm confident that if i
you know push forward i will eventually
be able to speak well
but here i felt i wanted to consolidate
what i had
before moving forward and it was more
difficult to move forward so that's one
thing that happened to me in persian
and greek i am sure that in doing that
you know
one tends to move in the direction of
the least resistance if it's not
difficult to move forward if i can grab
a polish
audiobook and ebook and basically know a
lot of the words from ukrainian russian
czech that's that's kind of the line of
least resistance if i find a lot of
resistance in moving towards more
difficult material then i tend to stay
with the easier stuff and i should say
that i have listened and i'm going to
show you how often i have listened to
who is she or
or
the mini stories but lots and lots of
times
and yet every time i go back and i
discover something else
uh first time i listened to it i didn't
didn't notice certain aspects of the
structure a certain words didn't stick
with me but then i see these structures
and these words elsewhere in other
stories or in who is she and then i go
back
and i noticed them a second time so that
i'm actually able to mine this sort of
beginner material
which is almost like a
you know after a while it's like a zen
chant you know you're just used to doing
it it's like getting on a treadmill it's
not difficult to do you just get on and
do it and but i'm i find that i pick up
stuff every time i pick up something
different so i'm not finished mining
that material i was listening to
the last couple of chapters of who is
she and there were still a lot of things
there that i would like to go back in
and and really integrate into my
basic knowledge in persian so my
strategy in arabic and persian has been
a bit of a departure from my previous
strategy for the reasons i just
explained
going forward uh well let me show you
that then uh on link and then we will uh
talk a bit more about it uh let's go
share my screen
uh i am going to call up my uh
okay let's call up arabic here
i haven't shared the screen yet have i
uh wait a second here share the screen
okay
click screen share
here
and start screen share
present to everyone
so this is my arabic
page this is how the different lessons
show up what different people are
studying but what i wanted to go to is
my profile here
so i click on the profile
and uh so
if i look at the last seven days you'll
see that
i wound down my arabic because i'm going
to be talking in persian so when i show
you the persian you'll see the persian's
been much more active but if i go for
the last
three months
then these are the known words so the
number of known words has grown
it has grown
but
if i were to show you
the growth of my known words in other
languages it has been much
faster so the daily is like 300 words a
day on average
uh
if i go to
um
speaking hours
you'll see again that it's been you know
gradually getting more and more i added
on uh tutors
towards the end because i wanted to
sort of improve my speaking capability
um
[Music]
let's see if i look at uh
listening
you know it's been pretty steady it's
been pretty steady gradually
increasing the cumulative
um
but if i
go
so that let's go to no known words this
is the interesting one so my known words
total
in arabic is 8337
and that's actually i started arabic
earlier so if i look at here
you know all time
so i started
my arabic back in december of 2017
and i was quite active for a while
and then i was
traveling
through here so i stopped doing much
and then
since
um
so look at you see very busy and adding
new words at the beginning but less so
here and if i then look at my listening
uh it kind of corresponds to that i was
very much more active through the early
part of 2018 than i have been since
in my arabic and this is because i
started doing
farsi
uh but still the uh
known words
sort of grew like this to a total of 8
357.
if i look at my check
uh
check
so
i think i would click that on in the
wrong spot but let's uh go to profile
here
if i look at my check
i've done nothing the last seven days
but if i look at all time
you'll see that my check i'm up at 66
000 known words
66 000 known words and those were
acquired furiously at the beginning
uh
and then
far fewer words thereafter and that's
because there's just so many
uh
words that come from russian i went to
check after russian but if i look at my
listening
again so most of my activity in check
was all at that one spurt but it's a
brief spurt a brief spurt so that it
just shows you that
with those languages where you can read
them they're in the latin alphabet
there's a lot of words you know you can
move pretty quickly to increase your
known words total just to a very large
number
also as you get into a language you
start to
quickly recognize different forms of the
same words and this all helps not the
case
in persian
so if i go back to here's where i should
be changing it let's go and look at my
persian here
uh where is it persian there we
go
so persian all time i mean i'm only at
2500 known words
uh
2500 known words
uh again most of it is basically in this
period in the last three months like
i've done the most adding of known words
in the oh no sorry this is listening
i've done most of the listening to
persian in the last three months i had a
brief period back in august when i
started listening and then i left it
didn't do anything
and then in the last three months
uh i've been working on my persian
uh if i look at speaking hours
you'll see that most of those speaking
hours again are in the most recent
period i mean he's you know three two
hours
and here
you know double basically
um
so that um
you know the fact of all that i'm
speaking like if if i go back briefly to
my
i'll see i haven't looked at these
numbers that much but let's go to my
check
where are we check check check
where did check go here
oh here we are check
if i go to speaking
you'll see that i started in
in no
december of 2011
but really did hardly any speaking
until
basically
i guess
the summer so six months before i was
doing any significant amount of speaking
six months
uh
whereas here in persian i'm speaking
after two or three months
even though so if we say you know august
2012 i'm speaking quite a bit august
2012
but what's my word count
at august 2012
august 2012 my word count is already 43
000. so
you know uh
i i really didn't start speaking at all
uh see here i had all these words
uh you know i was at 30 000 words i
wasn't speaking whereas now the strategy
has been
that i wanted to speak early the
question is if i had put the effort
into
adding more known words in persian or
arabic this would have delayed my
speaking
but maybe in the long run
i would have been better off doing that
uh the problem is that it's more
difficult to do
so as i uh take stock of what i have
learned well first of all going forward
i know that i'm going to put
both persian and arabic now on the back
burner let's look at the uh
let's just one last peek here before we
open things up where is the arabic again
portuguese italian
[Music]
where did the arabic go oh here we are
so the known words moves early there and
yet uh in terms of speaking hours
you know
i guess here again it was november where
i did a lot of speaking in arabic and
this has to do with the fact that i was
going to morocco and i wanted to
practice speaking in arabic before going
to morocco
but
in november of 2018
my known words
in november of 2018
2018 november you know it's like 6 000
words so whereas i waited to have 30 000
words to speak in czech i was speaking
in arabic at 6 000 words i was speaking
i'm now speaking in persian after 2 500
words
uh two things there one that it's harder
to move forward in these languages
because of the you know it's all new
vocabulary
and the writing system is strange and
the second thing is that the
availability of materials such as the
mini stories just gives me more
opportunity to work on things and to get
the structure down
so that
on the one hand i don't want to move
forward because it's tough it's
hard work and there's this availability
of other material that i can stay in so
just some thoughts on that
and uh i'd be interested in everyone's
comments and and their own views on on
what they have learned
during this period
uh so uh let's stop that
and here we are again all right now
let's see what people have to say
and blah blah blah let's go to the top
here first again check
the
the last live stream i wish it lasted
the entire year i will do some of these
live streams but i'm not going to do
them three times a week
um
now
blah blah blah he has had a couple
things they're doing once a week
australia but move to europe where in
europe last language workout
uh
live
but we'll just do it less frequently
ah aloha from texas
is there a native english speaker here
yeah good afternoon
just want to say thank you so much for
all your videos they have helped so much
in my language journey thank you i let
me tell you that every time someone says
that they appreciate these videos that
it encourages them it really makes me a
you know happy it's it's nice to be to
think that what i am doing what what we
do
is helpful to other people so i do
appreciate the feedback
okay not true but i'm working on it
uh your last video rock keep going
arabic is good i could understand a
little bit i am a native speaker of
arabic hello
blah blah blah but there are more
natives on language exchange learning
discord slack chat servers if you're
looking to chat blah blah blah who here
is drinking beer my last question about
meditation you didn't give me an answer
but what about doing sports is it
helpful running while listening to
podcasts to the language okay first of
all i don't do meditation so i can't
comment on how effective meditation is
i find that uh
running or
being active while listening to podcasts
i i have no
you know scientific proof but i think
that
being active is it's got to be good for
the brain too it's just your alert it's
energy is happening but i have no
scientific evidence of that
how have you managed to learn so many
languages please tell me your secret i
aspire to be a polyglot i am 14. okay
so
i i talk about it all the time
you know
the way you ha you have to expose the
brain to a lot of the
a lot of input in the language
there is i've read books on the subject
that our brains from uh evolutionary
perspective okay we are not so well
equipped to deal with theoretical
explanations
uh we are equipped to take in a lot of
stimulus the brain takes it in and sorts
it out and creates little
patterns networks in the brain to deal
with what's coming at it that's what our
brain has to do we have to be able to
cope in life we have to anticipate
what's going to happen we have to and so
therefore exposing ourselves to a lot of
content in the brain is the best way
nothing wrong with looking at grammar
once you have enough of the language in
you so that these grammar explanations
deal with something that you already
know so the secret is to find a lot of
content to listen and read occasionally
review grammar follow your curiosity
don't worry about how you perform
find ways to enjoy the language and you
will eventually improve and you can do
that in many different languages and
even though at times you'll confuse one
you know with one language with another
is this an arabic word is it a persian
word is it a japanese word you don't
worry about that you're going to make
mistakes it's possible to learn many
languages many languages no question
hello steve seriously thank you for all
your help after how many months do you
stop with listening things more than
once oh that reminds me i wanted to show
you something lucas question
you have a sense that you don't want to
listen more than once anymore you want
to move on once you're good enough
you're at that sort of intermediate
stage now you want to
get into things of interest whether it
be literature history songs whatever
you're interested in so you're now more
listening and reading
out of interest and less out of a
deliberate effort to improve in the
language but i wanted to show you
something so i'm going to
share my screen one more time
and the screen share
all right
so
uh now let's have a look here i wanted
to show you
my playlist
uh so let's go to lessons here
and um
now where it was i can't remember where
i put the playlist here oh here we are
playlist
okay so we are in check so there's
nothing there
but if we go to uh
you know gujarati i was at dinner the
other night and the chef was
an ismaili who speaks gujarati maybe one
day who knows so persian
and
playlist and
let me point out that the playlist
is very important and now you have the
ability the ability to to listen to
create a playlist out of any course
uh do it it's very powerful so
story 16 16 times
um
stories 1 to 15 i have listened to more
often some of these stories 21 times
you'll just you'll see and obviously
further on you listen less and less
often but this nazi i mean this is a
a tutors report
she gives me nazi gives me five minutes
six minutes four minutes
of her notes of our conversation so i've
listened to these tutor reports 13 times
this is rana 11 times
okay
so nazi seven times so here's a story
for a mini story ten times i know these
later many stories last well because i
haven't listened as often
so uh often yeah listen often if i go to
my arabic
and i just wanted to make this point
because i think people don't listen
enough
uh where did arabic go to here green guy
arabic
so if i go to my playlist
and uh here again you know and i started
with arabic uh 42 times less than 13. i
shudder to think how many times i've
listened to stories one two three four
five 40 times story 16 76 times
50 times look at how often i've listened
listen to these stories the thing about
having a playlist is it tracks your
listening so you have a record of how
often you've listened
people don't listen enough
uh
63 times i've listened to this story 63
times
um
so and one thing i wanted to show you
again here
is if you upload say assimil
and uh oh
or maybe i don't have the most recent
version or maybe it's no i think you can
not sure where it is on the um
on the uh
what does this say
uh uh on the app you can um play the
whole course
listen to the audio of the course and
turn it immediately into a playlist i
think there is somewhere you can do that
on the main on the website but i don't
know where that is i will have to find
out i'm sorry okay
anyway we'll but if it isn't there it
will be soon and it's very important you
know make a playlist out of the audio
which tells you how often you've
listened to it
and uh
you know it tells you what your total
listing is i often think we should have
a daily thing that pops up on your
mobile phone
today how often did i listen how much
did i listen
uh we need to push people into listening
more in my opinion
but uh yeah people may think otherwise
so
that was an answer to luca so when do i
stop doing that when i feel like it uh
there's nothing more scientific than
that
uh steve goat thanks to from brazil very
important i'm
absolutely absolutely uh i encourage
people
you know
i don't know what the definition of
middle age is but i'm certainly past
middle age
uh we will have more language corners
three thousand non-words current device
is the gap between those numbers that
determine as far as the number of
targets you can speak on or the depth
you can speak about well of course
charles yes i mean
you need words to discuss certain
subjects uh and to have a
you'll if you listen to my persian
check the time here you'll see that
there's a limited number of things i can
talk about without having to ask the
tutor every time how do you see this how
do you say that how do you say this now
the advantage is when i talk to my tutor
and we're wondering in the subjects that
i don't have the vocabulary for i ask
the tutor how do you say this in arabic
or persian
she says it to me makes no impression on
me i don't get it like she can say it
five times i won't get it but
she puts that in the report
so from my tutor i get a report and in
the case of one of them it's a five
minute recording
of all the words and phrases that i
either got wrong
or i didn't know the word for and so now
i have a lesson so yesterday for example
i had my lesson then i had this five
minute recording or it was actually six
minutes then i listened to that
recording five times while cleaning up
after breakfast and cleaning up the
kitchen and everything else so i'm
listening to it i'm curious i'm
listening to it i'm curious curious is
good when you're curious then i go to
the text of her
conversation report and i start saving
words and phrases and then i listen
again
slowly this so so your conversation with
your tutor if you wander into areas that
you don't have the vocabulary for
it is an opportunity to create more
input more content that you can learn
the vocabulary from
now
the word link word count depends on how
inflected each language is yes
absolutely yeah so therefore there's no
absolute value to those numbers uh you
can't compare from one language to the
next
uh
so is it a good method to learn a
language using another language which
shares similarities i don't think it
matters
so uh you know i can use uh you know you
can use english to learn chinese uh
uh
it can be interesting like i yeah
actually you know what when i think
about it florian vasilev it can be
interesting like sometimes uh if i'm
learning a slavic language i like to
have russian as a reference because then
you see whether the word is similar or
not similar so i think you can go both
ways on this
after how many minutes have learned you
find it easy to listen anything that you
want in romance languages uh you know
it's hard to say but if you are already
a speaker of a romance language then it
should go fairly quickly
i find it possible to read and listen at
the same time in chinese when you were
learning chinese japanese did you listen
at the same time
no in those days they didn't have that
kind of thing you know in those days i
listened i listened i listened then i
would go read and read and read we
didn't have computers
uh
so it takes a long time to get to where
you can read as quickly as you can
listen
so
you know it's not surprising that you
find it difficult to do that
is it poke understand anime in japanese
after reading and listening for seven
hours every day if you read a lesson
seven hours a day you'll understand a
lot a lot
you know you'll be able to do anything
in japanese
uh
thank you for helping me
learn the languages reading
comprehension i wish i knew this when i
started been learning spanish in spain
the last two and a half years yeah i
can't
stress enough the importance of
listening and reading that doesn't take
away from other things that you can do
you can speak you can
you know look up grammar you can do all
kinds of other stuff but the core
the basis upon which your language
skills will improve is your ability to
understand your comprehension that means
vocabulary and it means lots of
listening and reading lots
uh
spanish many stories is a good start
absolutely watching anime for seven
hours a day for a year i don't recommend
that watching it for one hour a day so i
don't watch anime i thought you meant
listening and reading in general so i
don't know what anime involves whether
there's just a lot of pictures going on
or what
have you tried using anchor flash cards
uh i don't you do a lot of
i don't do anki i do
the five activities call them flash
cards at link when i turn the page in a
lesson especially in the early stages or
if i'm reviewing a lesson rather than
reading the whole lesson through i'll
just go through the yellow words that
i've saved there but other than that
i simply don't have enough time to
devote a half hour or an hour a day to
reviewing words and phrases i would
rather spend that time reading and
listening
how do you usually handle not
understanding a particular statement or
question in a conversation is it better
to say something or pretend that you
understand it
uh you know it's hard to say
i tend to you know if i feel that it's
not crucial to the conversation i'll let
it go especially if i'm asking a lot of
questions however if i think it's
important i'll ask it depends on the
conversation if it's a conversation with
a tutor i'm more likely to ask for the
explanation
if it's a conversation where we're
trying to communicate about something
specific and i i feel we're kind of
communicating but i missed certain
things i'll just let it go
is it a good way to practice speaking
listening to
positive or many stories and make a
summary of what you heard
okay like i don't do that kind of stuff
probably a good thing to do i just am
too uh i'm not disciplined enough to do
that so i listen i listen i read i read
i don't understand i listen again i read
again i don't make summaries probably a
good thing to do i don't do it
when you um here steve i hear people say
that if you're not studying in the
target language for at least one hour
every day you're not trying hard enough
some people are legit very busy no
matter how determined jared okay
you know i think an hour a day is kind
of good once you try to do an hour a day
how do you get to an hour a day it's
listening listening is extremely
powerful listening
drives your language learning listening
makes you curious because you don't
understand what you're listening to so
you go and read it and then maybe you
say words and phrases if you're unlinked
and then the structure is confusing and
you might look up the grammar but
listening to me listening drives my
learning i can always find time to
listen i can listen while cleaning up in
the kitchen i can listen while
exercising i can listen in my car listen
on the train
listening that's why i think we should
have something on the phone reminding
people
listen
listen you can always accumulate five
minutes here ten minutes there you can
accumulate an hour of listening if you
do the the hour of listening
chances are you'll follow up because you
won't understand it all so you'll follow
up and do the reading and and other work
that you need to do that's why for
example listening to the audio of a
course is great because you just set it
up there and you hear it it's on your
playlist the playlist
uh course playlist all of this stuff
anything that facilitates listening is
very good because it makes it likely
that you'll get in an hour a day with
the language
blah blah blah okay thanks that was
bugging me when you say that you listen
in the beginning 40 times you listen to
the same text many times every day you
listen first and after a few days okay
lucas question so no i don't listen to
the same thing over and over again you
can't
the the
one of the
sort of lines that i took out of manfred
spitzer's book on how the brain learns
is the brain needs repetition and
novelty so i do less than one
i understand half of it and then i go to
lesson two i'm curious i want to see
lesson two now even though i didn't
understand lesson one i'm curious about
lesson two and then i go to lesson three
and lesson four and less than five and
then i go back to lesson one
and then i go up to ten and go back to
lesson one and then i might do something
else and then i'll come back so it's
very much a matter of going back to it
over and over and over again
uh that's why the playlist is good so
you're not and i seldom put the playlist
on repeat which you can do so that i
hear the same thing over and over and
over again because repetition and
novelty if it's just repetition
the efficiency goes down the brain loses
interest
those don't really help me i don't like
them and none of that
is that you just said that
yeah
so more input is going to help you
accumul you know acquire the language
love all your videos since starting my
language learning journey through early
enjoy you and your passion and
perspective you are tremendously
experienced placebo thank you very much
wild child namaste
i want to practice okay is it okay to
learn russian and swedish at the same
time will it slow down my process of
adopting these languages okay now i've
had this experience of learning two
languages
i mean
it works both ways on the one hand if
like i sense like if i stayed on my
arabic and only did arabic for three
months i would be further ahead i really
get into it you start to get a toehold
like i did you know i shut down my
persian for five days just focused on
arabic and i noticed i improved more so
there is tremendous advantage in
concentrating in one however if you are
curious about two languages and want to
maintain that curiosity
then you can try it you may find that
you end up spending more time on one
language than on the other
steve what do you think about novelty
fictional languages like klingon and
hive valerian or whatever
zero interest zero okay i'm interested
in languages and travel and food and
culture and meeting people i have no
interest in artificial languages and i
include and despite the criticism i'm
going to get i include in that esperanto
that's not to say others shouldn't be
interested in those things i'm not
if that's that doesn't interest you i'd
definitely suggest like watching videos
and blah blah blah i can't wait for you
to start learning turkish greetings from
venezuela greetings hey steve i from
india i want to learn spanish i'm still
struggling so much with it give me
advice anant get on link and use the
mini stories on link
i got another question is it helpful
learning the languages very deeply aj ho
taught me that because most teachers
unfortunately take one chapter in one
textbook after one week move on to the
next i don't fully understand it but
you know one of the problems in any
classroom environment is that the
teacher controls what you learn
as an independent learner and even if
you're in a classroom you should move on
when you feel like it you don't have to
100
master any chapter you curious about the
next chapter you just move on go on two
three four five back to one
however you are motivated that's what
you should be doing
i think it's my first language and i'm
too lazy to learn other things that's
fine can you explain why pronunciation
is overlooked in schools um
various things first of all very often
in schools the teacher is not a native
speaker so the teacher is not the best
model for pronunciation
uh two
you know pronunciation is a bit like
grammar you have to hear a lot of it
before you have a chance of
pronouncing it properly so i think the
question rather should be
why is listening comprehension not
promoted more in schools if people
listened hours and listened to hours and
hours and hours
they would start to hear the differences
in the pronunciation and then they would
have a better chance of
pronouncing well
pronunciation is not something in my
opinion that should be focused on at the
beginning
i read an article from lucas saying that
the quicker you learn something the
quicker you can forget it would this
imply that it's better to learn
something over the long time rather than
intensively
well i have tremendous respect for luca
but i don't believe that i have found
the other the opposite to be true the
more intensive you learn something the
better you learn it you're you're
burning the the sort of connections but
you have to stay with it
if maybe luca meant that if you learn a
language in two months and go away and
come back you'll be it'll be more
difficult to recover what you have
learned than if you have spent six
months at the language so the point
there is to make sure you put in enough
time to reach sort of a critical mass in
the language
but the more intensively you study the
faster you move and i remember thinking
after my chinese learning experience 50
years ago
that if i learned the same amount of
material in six months as opposed to 12
months i don't learn it twice as well i
learn it four times as well so i'm a big
believer in intensity in language
learning
i am a huge fan thank you
ninja i want to say thank you for
sharing your knowledge about language
learning your videos really helped me
i'm glad that makes me very glad to hear
that
likes my glasses
prepositions in spanish are defeating me
any suggestions
uh you know anything in another language
that is
call it strange different not what we're
used to in our own language is going to
be difficult i have that experience in
slavic languages now month of may i'm
tooling up to go to ukraine i'm going to
try to improve my control of cases and
verbs aspects verbs of motion all that
kind of stuff it's difficult to create
new habits
so you have to just say okay with enough
exposure and because the prepositions
are attached to something they're either
attached to a verb or attached to a noun
save if you're on link save phrases
review the phrases
um
you know if you have saved phrases then
uh if you're on link then you do the
activities you can do the dictation so
you can hit those phrases maybe you go
into link and you only save phrases with
these prepositions that give you trouble
so forget about all the words you don't
know just focus on the prepositions and
then go through the activities do them
in flashcard do them in dictation where
you have to you hear the text of speech
you have to type it do them in multiple
choice do them in different ways so that
there's a certain amount of variety
remember we we need novelty there's a
certain amount of randomness and you're
reviewing the prepositions notice them
when you listen and read hear them when
you listen
uh and slowly the brain will acquire
this habit
forget the explanations i mean you can
review the explanations but it's one of
these things that doesn't stay with you
very long you have to develop the habit
where are we here prepositions what do
you think of french in action i'm sorry
i don't know it i'm learning russian do
you have a suggestion for me enjoy it
it's my only suggestion it's a lovely
language tremendous amount of literature
and a tremendous amount of 19th century
literature for which there are
spectacular audiobooks you can import
the ebook into link and and just enjoy
the language and just and don't be
impatient don't be impatient about your
ability to remember different case
endings especially when speaking
focus on comprehension
and really get to the point where you
understand it well then you will be able
to improve your speaking
much more easily
huh do you start listening or reading or
at the same time it varies sometimes i
read first sometimes i listen first
you know if i'm going out the door i'll
grab something to listen to that i
haven't read
if i'm at home i might decide to push
forward and read something and then i
listen to it and that'll be my listening
for the next day no hard and fast rule
what percentage of words should you know
before you read advanced content like
novels on link
it also depends on
the uh language
but
i think 10 15 000
you know i was working on advanced
novels in russian at a much lower level
at a time when link was very slow and
clunky so it depends on your interest
your motivation how difficult the
language is
no hard and fast rule
do you recommend finishing courses we
start start mini stories no i don't
recommend finishing courses
the advantage of link is that you can be
in this for a while then go do something
else and then come back to the many
stories many stories to me is a place to
start but it's also a place that you can
always go back to
and it's like a training room because
it's the it uses the most common verbs
in the language a lot of the good
connecting words like although because
however on the other hand and so it's a
place to go back and refresh and review
and renew and then you can go back to
stuff that you find more interesting
i'm learning japanese my level is lower
intermediate should i start learning
hiragana kataka and kanji
i don't know you know the way i learn i
don't know how you can learn vocabulary
without being able to read so i would
definitely get into hiragana katakana as
soon as possible and i would start
learning kanji
does it bother you when people don't
care if you can speak their native
language at a good level it bothers me
and i don't like it doesn't bother me
however while i speak that's how well i
speak i don't do it for other people
doesn't bother me
did you learn the cases in russian check
just by reading or did you also consult
grammar books of course i can start
grammar books i consult grammar books
though
for an overview of what's happening
the more familiar i am with the language
the more these explanations make sense
and yet i can't remember them
so it's a combination of a lot of
listening and reading
so that certain phrases now start to
sound in your mind and they embody the
correct case and occasionally reviewing
the explanations
mr steve also tried i've always tried to
learn french i studied a week and then i
stopped please should i listen and read
simple things and not google on the
words whatever well i mean
what should people ask what they should
do lots of listening and reading uh if
you
you know
look things up for sure i mean i
devised link
in a way that once we look something up
we have a record of the fact that we
looked it up because we're gonna forget
it don't rely on having looked up a word
and think you're gonna learn it you
won't you'll forget it
it's it's just an ongoing process
okay yes peruvian easy to learn
languages when i was in cusco
all the taxi drivers spoke
uh what he called quechua as well as
spanish very impressive
uh yes it's effective to go uh and talk
to people how hard is japanese grammar i
didn't find it hard
uh
how you increase your link quantities
thousands in a short time
okay well it depends on the language
you're starting with if i
if i have russian then i can increase my
vocabulary in check
if i have ukrainian i can increase my
vocabulary in polish quickly okay if you
have spanish you can increase your
vocabulary in french quickly it depends
what the base language is
is it possible to learn three languages
at the same time i've never tried it you
know
try it
are non-fiction audio books
better it depends on your interests are
they easier yes non-fiction to me is
always easier than fiction
what would your advice
you advise my cousin is struggling with
carrying with spanish because he's
lacking always the motivation well it's
hard to motivate other people especially
your cousin
you know if if your cousin finds
something of interest in spanish music
whatever it might be go for it otherwise
uh leave him alone that's my advice do
you think it's good to learn a hundred
words a day but counting for example
eating a zestler
that's the way we count them at link so
in some languages you pick up a lot
but it's not obvious to people that ate
is the past tense of eat
it's not obvious that eaten
is uh you know whatever they call it
form of eat so i like to learn the
different forms did you learn hindi any
tips on learning hindi no but i hope to
get there
i speak ivan jesus says i speak any
spanish portuguese nominees are not
difficult i find
well there's no difference it's just
that russian is harder because you go
from english to spanish okay
english is 50 60 latin based words from
spanish to portuguese you got all the
words before you start now you're going
into a language where there may only be
10 or 15 words that you can identify
it's just harder but it's the same
uh which chinese dialect do you think
you should learn
it depends what your needs are if you're
in hong kong learn cantonese if you're
in shanghai you might learn shanghainese
if you're in taiwan you might learn
taiwanese otherwise for sure you have to
learn mandarin
sends me audio the many stories i listen
to that for hours but it doesn't seem to
help me remember okay there's research
showing that exercise is excellent for
both depression and learning i wouldn't
doubt it
i had what japanese was your personal
favorite it depended on where i was but
i did listen to this series of cassette
tapes from nhk the national broadcaster
in japan called showa no kiroku which
talked about the history of the showa
era with a lot of you know real-time
news from the era it was great
uh how can i learn to use the four tones
in madrid chinese i can't and it is
frustrating me and i'm okay with that
i'm going to have to leave because i
want to warm up a little bit for my
persian exit interview
the tones i said before
you can look at the individual tone per
word it's hard to remember
learn them as phrases
lots of listening and i found listening
to xiangshuang which is these chinese
comic dialogues where the comedians
exaggerate the tones was very helpful
uh how can i learn okay how are the many
stories made all right amir yeah
we would love to have more mini stories
i paid a person actually an english
teacher in japan a canadian woman
to write the stories
she wrote these 60 stories i think she
did a fabulous job and then we simply
translated them into other languages and
had them recorded if anybody wants to
produce many stories in any language we
are interested
okay
all right i'm going to run now thank you
and good luck to all and we'll have
another 90-day challenge and uh we'll
have more of these sessions as well bye